[Music]
in this video we will continue to
discuss contact forces contact forces
are the forces that act between the
objects when the objects are in contact
with each other we have already
discussed what a muscular forces it is
the force that is generated due to the
actions of muscles in our body when a
body is applied force on any object
muscular force is a contact force
another contact force that we can talk
of is the force of friction what is
force of friction try rolling the ball
on a horizontal plane surface what do
you notice you noticed that this ball
gradually slows down after some time and
eventually comes to a halt why does this
happen why during the ball continue to
move in the same direction forever the
reason for a slowing down and ultimately
stopping if the forced active surface
applies on the ball when it's moving yes
the surface applies the force on the
ball and the direction of this force is
opposite to that of the motion so when
the ball was traveling towards the right
the surface was applying a force on it
towards the left the force applied on
the ball by the surface it's called a
force of friction or simply friction
friction plays quite an important role
in our daily life we can walk and run
because of friction how does it help us
walk when we walk forward we push the
ground with a foot in the backward
direction in return the ground exerts a
force in the forward direction which
moves us forward the force that the
ground exerts is nothing but the force
of friction the examples that we've seen
till now are the ones in which the
frictional force exists between solid
objects now consider a boat moving in a
quiet lake in order for this boat to
move the person in the boat must
continuously row it
now if he stops drawing it will the boat
move forward no just like the rolling
ball stopped at the solid surface the
boat will also stop eventually in water
it stops because of the force of
friction between the water and the
surface of the boat which is in contact
with the water so from all the examples
that we've seen in this video what can
you conclude about the force of friction
is it a contact force we see that in the
first example the ball was in contact
with the surface in the second example
the foot was in contact with the ground
and finally the boat was in contact with
the surface of water so we can safely
say that force of friction is indeed a
contact force but it's contact between
the objects necessary for the force to
act between them we will see that in the
next video
[Music]